is there a way to be a straight-shooter
nope sorry is there a way to be straight
shooter Jocko and not be a jerk or piss
people off you know this is this is a
touchy one mm-hmm because everybody want
everybody has so much respect for the
straight shooter right hey that guy's a
straight shooter and you want to be a
straight shooter you don't want to be
someone that you don't want to be the
opposite what's the opposite of a
straight shooter that's like a liar
right deceiver a deceiver right yeah so
of course we want to be the straight
shooter let me tell you it is very
difficult to be a straight shooter with
everybody mm-hmm even when you have a
tremendous relationship with somebody a
tremendous relationship with somebody
can you really be a straight shooter
with them a true straight shooter I've
been a true straight shooter with
probably three or four people in my life
in my life
administrates you with maybe three or
four people mm-hmm that's off the top of
my head but I'm just saying it's not a
big number it's got to be something that
you are so in sync with man I'm thinking
about that I don't think that's even
possible for me and my situation even
though because it's a straight shooter
yeah how can you reconcile being a
straight straight shooter now consider
what that means but to be a straight
shooter with somebody at all times yeah
that really do that yeah so so what do
we do instead you gotta use the indirect
approach mmm the indirect approach now
I'm talking about this all the time and
this is a nuance that people people
won't people come out on podcast 12 and
they say hey I heard you say this or not
I'm gonna go remember that question we
got asked you know do you ever get told
your turn direction too intense it's
like no I don't get told that right
because I don't believe in being trying
to be a straight shooter with everybody
what I believe in is trying to get my
message across to people so that it gets
some sorbets by them and the minute you
straight shoot somebody their defenses
go up and it becomes problematic so some
indirect approaches or
you have these discussions with people
when you use conversation to get your
point across you know hey I was looking
at this and I was wondering what I could
do better can you can you help me or you
know what can we do better you know you
were throwing the the we on it or you
know well then you say something like a
you know you've got so much going on
right now mm-hmm
you want me to take anything off you
play you want to take that thing off
your plate that that's kind of like a
small little detail do you want me to
handle that or you know hey it seems
like you're having a micromanage this
guy over here you want it you want it
nobody go straighten that out and run
that or it seems like this guy's taking
up too much of your time you want me to
take that over or take that person over
or you know what's a good one
is hey can you help me with my team
members I just want to sit down with you
and just like have you talked to me
about what you see in my team members
and then when you're you're you're
discussing your team members and other
people even your peers and what they do
getting bad but what you're really doing
is you're just tossing some things there
away some little things their way so
that they understand and they it and
it's kind of like teaching jujitsu right
when you teach it when you teach them or
teaching anything when you teach a move
you learn it better right mm-hmm if you
make somebody teach a move they're gonna
learn it better so when you make someone
sit down with you and go through the
issues that people are having it
actually makes them self reflect but
they don't know it but they reap the
results they reap the results of it so
that's a that's a crafty one that I've
used a bunch let's see here's a good one
I think I'm letting you down I don't
think I'm doing a good enough job you
know it's like I think I'm just be
careful though it down seems like if you
if you hit the wrong tone oh my goodness
you got to be careful with all these you
got to be tactful yeah you can ask some
more direct questions but when you ask
them more direct questions you got to be
sort of you're gonna be true you gotta
be you gotta come across as being very
truthful in your in your Inquisition so
for instance hey what was the strategy
that you were
thinking about over here like before
this whole thing fell apart and it's a
half part but yo hey do you think there
or hey what was what were you thinking
about when you put this together cuz I I
don't quite I don't quite get it you got
to be careful that's another one you got
to be sensitive you look at home kid
come off that home can come off bad what
were you thinking right well hey yeah
you gotta be soft with you so it's much
better to be indirect in most of these
cases and hopefully you can build
relationships with people where you can
be more direct or you can do get that
conversation to be where it needs to be
to where you can get the key critical
information across but it's very very
challenging yeah and again in a it's not
not challenging it's not impossible I
did it with everybody all the time I
always had got my point across to people
hmm always you know and I'll tell you
this is something when I would straight
shoot somebody I would and this is if I
really needed to straight shoot somebody
I would write them a very lengthy email
hmm to say hey here's what's going on
here's what I'm saying and I would
really craft it with a lot of patience
and and then I would either do once I
wrote the email I would either use that
and wouldn't send it but I'd use it as a
guide to myself like okay this is the
conversation of and a half or I'd send
it to him for real like it needs note
yeah like a DL note you know I actually
read one of I read one of those on on on
or two it's number five I think it was
number five that was one of those things
that I did I said okay you know what I
gotta help this guy out
got to be direct with him he's making
some mistakes I want him to do better
here's a little DL note for you get you
squared away the thing is these this is
definitely hard but it's not impossible
you've got to just have the open mind
you gotta use your tact you got to use
your judgment and you gotta build
relationships and have conversations
with people mm-hmm and know what your
intention is in the conversation and
just keep slowly moving in that
direction
you know what a a tip and i'ma say this
tip because I like when people do it to
me when they're like correcting me or
whatever is sprinkle in little comments
about the stuff that they did right yeah
that's a common practice yeah but when
you do that though you add in this yet
in that's what I like about you you do
this you know so it's you know so if you
add in that's what I like about you it
kind of individualizes that person like
I'm the guy who does that you know that
good part so it gives them that
confidence so it's kind of like yeah
tell me more kind of kind of attitude
and then at the end throw in like
something along the lines of like yeah
good thanks you know thanks for the time
or whatever and then be like I got your
back yeah kind of leave yeah there's all
kinds we could go over techniques all
night long those are both good ones you
know another one is like hey listen I
think you can be a top performer here
mm-hmm I think you're gonna this is if
you're talking to someone that's you
know like a subordinate I think you
could be a top performer here there's
here's what you're kicking ass at yes
this this and this here's this these two
things right here
if we can get these fixed you're going
platinum when we get these things when
we look at you yeah I'm imagining in the
sense of you telling me this like
jiu-jitsu so yeah you know yeah just say
like when I'd be like hey and I'd ask
him this I'm in this position and he'd
be like be like Kevin later on you know
I'd text him water behaves for for going
over this with me it's like a pro you
don't keep it up and you can be like a
world champion he'd just say that and I
don't know who else easy process that
everybody I don't know he's never said
that to me that's cuz we each other
before that moment I'm like hell yeah
you know like I hope he corrects me more
I hope he tells me how to do this
because he obviously bleed just like are
you saying you know you could be a top
performer here yeah tell me what else
what can I do what can I do on this and
actually the point that you're making is
very good point which is you know
picture go into perspective of the other
person and what is it gonna sound like
to them and that's that's a smart thing
to do so you're you're hearing what you
would hear if you were them yeah
yeah indirect people be indirect it's
harder it's challenging it takes more
time it takes more patience and it is
way more effective mm-hmm fact yeah and
we talked about how before like some
people they'll be like hey I'm just I'm
just
I tell it how it is you know I tell how
it is and and if you don't like you kind
of thing and all right go ahead and do
that but see how that works out for you
you know see how many people follow you
so many people want to listen to you you
know other people want to be around you
even you know I like the indirect
approach to